[Norvig] And the answer is it will take about N squared on average.
It will be more time proportional to N squared.
And the way you can see that is to think about how long it's going to take
to get the very last item of this swapped array filled in.
So say all the items are true all the way through,
except there's 1 holdout that we haven't got yet. This one is still false.
About how long will it take until we randomly choose a number
so that we can make this one be true?
And the answer is there's N of these.
And each time we're going through and we're generating indices,
so it's going to take about N random numbers before we get that.
So for each of these N elements of the array
we can expect on average to take N or less.
For the first one it will be easy.
The second one will be a little bit harder. The last few it will be harder still.
But in the average case, the complexity is going to be on the order
of N times generating a random number for each of the N elements of that array
or order of N squared altogether.